yeah to call a fan where he's a he's a
Christian pastor you know what the
Christian pastor you will have them like
finish it up with a prayer for us
perhaps okay let me get one question
well do that while I get Adam T showing
on reddit says oh it's for Gilbert oh
geez alright Gilbert tell me about your
experience at Second City what are some
of the most valuable and attributes SC
instilled on you through a comedy and
theater aspect we slept gang balmy Sun
back I'll tell you you would have been
one of the youth video craft right and
it's like you got to be immersed no just
take classes do shows oh my god slept
King bobbies yeah John there we go is
that [ __ ] worth it what the Second City
and all that stuff I've always I've
always thought that comedy institutions
are the way to go Groundlings groundling
second city because in this world where
anyone can [ __ ] pick up a camera and
do a sketch in their living room that's
right that's when you when you can get
through the politics of an institution
and rise within that environment you're
being vetted by other people like The
Groundlings the people that pass you are
other sketch people they've been around
for hundreds of years
so I think that ya know I'm gonna just
read that wallet cause I'm I like
talking to people on the phone oh my god
Bobby we prepped you I'm a pastor I know
but I just realized I don't like it I'm
a pastor and a Methodist Church in
Albuquerque New Mexico
I've been following Bobby Lee's career
selling on TV I loved Tiger belly is it
calling yeah I [ __ ] up oh yeah Pisa
George you do what sorry guys
you you [ __ ] you and this is leave a
message
brass there what master you pester kill
kill
does he know we were in a call okay
hello pastor Gil this is Bobby Lee from
the tire belly podcast you submitted
your number to be on the hundredth
episode and I find it to be very rude
that you didn't pick up your [ __ ]
phone that it's going straight to a
[ __ ] voicemail dude I know it's a
buffer I know you believe in the Lord
and the Lord's on your side and you're
the spirit your spirit to a man okay but
just leave it that's why but let me tell
you some [ __ ] man oh no I'm sorry my
apart a pastor sir we love you we love
you pastor God but anyway sir I'm nah I
apologize cuz I know you're with the law
I sorry don't get that let the Lord gave
me cancer or nothing I feel free I won't
be free amen amen but I just want to say
that it's a little rude that on you put
your number in and then now I'm back got
a voicemail and now we're not gonna call
you back again because it's I can't do
it you know I'm in but um it's a [ __ ]
next time [ __ ] just don't do it then
okay ding dong ding dong who's first
ding dong oh where are the guests home
everybody
[Music]